alors les chirurgie la boîte à poux cave
merci et olala à une rumeur d'hier et
alors je vous jure je ne sais pas qui a
mis ça je vais découvrir dirais que
benjamin castaldi aurait de faux
pectoraux et de faux abdou est ce que
c'est vrai alors c'est entièrement faux
jour là mais vous voulez toucher bah euh
bah c'est le génial dire les pecs bages
le regarde vas-y toi je reviendrai qui
se déshabille attention c'est pas mal là
là bas salaires vrai l'epec marge pour
de vrai en une semaine
c est ce qu on peut alors s est pas
demain est ce que demain on peut amener
un truc comme dans les aéroports
bah oui on voit vraiment rating à
l'intérieur de son pari comment on
travaille on parie vas-y on parie batata
nîmes pendant une semaine touche pas à
mon poste si j'ai des faux ouais ou
abdos ou truc vrai ou pas mais j'ai rien
de faux d'akon de faux et pourquoi le
public seraient punis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
boubacar badji
je rejoins et je vois tu le soir venu a
été le seul à me défendre en tunisie oui
je la joue blair ait jamais défendre
quoi elle nous amène à un énorme coup de
coeur pour quelqu un coup de coeur alors
je pense s'est calmé ouais elle a un
coup de coeur pour quelqu'un une
évidence mais quelqu'un dit si oui non
non quelqu'un du viiie arrondissement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour vous annoncer pas pour moi
mais attendait peut-être qu'elle va
cesser quand même c'est pas demain parce
que lorsque je le sais à bombay na c'est
une évidence
non tu n'en es pas de chapelle à fermer
je vais vous dire j'ai les images un
regard des regards de ses produits à ce
moment là alors les images voilà mais
c'est qui
alors c'est pour cela que j'ai un petit
corps pour doc gynéco mais vous avez un
coup de coeur pour lui donne une écoute
là s'il te plaît parce que les ddd
écoute là mais pas coutume afin d'avoir
tous les ans après donc tu écoutes là il
ya quelqu'un qui te kiffe là mais gégé
j'ai trop aimé le fait que doc gynéco en
fait il allait se balader à ahmed je
pense à m il allait se balader dans les
rues à côté des petits magasins et où
ils étaient en train de distribuer de
l'argent non ouais pour des mendiants
j'aimerais pour des personnes qu'il
avait senti des personnes en besoin
d'argent et
c'était juste la connaissez ou at-il
jolie ses membres en vue d'un double non
[Applaudissements]
je le connais bien c'est mon avis et il
fait tout le temps ça voilà je voulais
bien que très discrètement
personne n'avait pas débuté c'est pour
ça que la mini jeux matures du roumanie
et mémé et mélina a eu un coup de coeur
pour d'autres bravo donc à manger d'un
cottage et achats gamma va me chercher
une bouteille d'eau
bravo mon dock franchement dragon désolé
je n'ai pas ramené les lunettes et où
vous croyez chez votre merde non médoc
c'est bon et docks a par contre là je
vais tout casser parce que il est donc à
fantasmer sur francesca tout le week-end
non non ça c'est pas fouet c'est pas
faux ça va vous dépouillent câble non
mais ça donc c'est vrai non j'ai passé
un petit moment avec elle elle était
seul isolé
tu rigoles on a passé tout le temps s'il
aimait bien tu l'aimé bien assez
[Rires]
demain tu as envie de la voir demain
ouais ouais
les contrats et tu l'as tu la quittes ou
pas wall est sympa ah bah ouais je pense
qu'on s'est même très ravissante oui
quoi oui ça aurait pu être une miss oui
oui oui mais des santiags ici et donc
c'est au style de musique non les deux
noms les sexy et elle et elle est sexy
je préfère en fait les filles plus
naturel et tout ça mais sexy ça plaît
aussi
ah ouais d'accord sekita fille préférée
dans tpm pays même si une petite part un
mois moi je crois savoir moi et bien à
mes yeux valérie est une star faut
qu'elle reste comme elle est celle reste
comme il est pour moi c'est comme si
elle est énorme à cet âge-là changera
plus ah bah là je sais pas quand à 100 m
il arrivait que tu m'a changé non mais
c'est vrai nom mais ça y est elle allée
à l'eba l'assaillent hélas hélas ça
bouge plus l'art de gâcher ta bouche
attend ben bien elle est de plus en plus
belle la bcb n'a pas préféré
ouais c'est sûr qu'il y ait dit non non
non c'est vraiment brillé c'est pas
qu'abby physiquement qui lui aussi est
comme elle est elle même mais quand elle
parle bien compris donc attiré par son
président kita préféré c'est kelly ou
cbd mcv naïm el mais très peu de
maquillage aller comme elle va venir en
boubou demain un an qu'elles courent
moins vite aussi s'il vous plaît cessé
de m'appeler bébé les gens c'est un
supporter téléspectateurs dont nous
avons c'est bref oui bon alors amour je
m'appelais cyril j'ai fait il met sur
baba un patron d'accor à les patrons
c'est hyper malaisie j'ai refait ma
balesi voulais juste dire quelque chose
voulez vous rendre hommage avec le
hashtag je n'ai pas vu sur twitter je
préférais vous le dire en vrai les trois
jours où vous n'étiez pas là et on
n'était pas ensemble
en tunisie du coup j'ai couché qu'une
personne et j'ai cherché longtemps
longtemps pour avoir un série de noms
oui c'est un échec ainsi rim sera très
très beau mais je voulais le prénom donc
j'ai couché avec de cyril je veux rendre
hommage
ah ouais et la tunisie est alors un
tunisien à la tunisie de ben ali était
pas tunisien côté je pouvais pas tout
faire y avait pas tous les deux j'ai pas
compris millionnaire j'ai pris ce qu'ils
avaient bon oeil à ce brave cyril à la
coiffe et prince il y est et s'il faut
bien passer à brume ce jeu cesu c'est
mignon comme ça on est rendu compte de
quoi bas que c'était pas le le cirill du
cirill je disais cyril mais je pensais
cyril à web alors vous ne pensez plus
indique cyril et penser jean-marc allez
vous le dire ou jean michel aphatie
mauvaise idée mais un ou deux docks a
donc il est quoi hétérosexuels
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci
les québécois doc
non il était tout seul mais j'ai
tellement chou est tellement mignon et
très tactile est vrai qu'un jour tu m'as
lancer une tablette lui tu m'avais dit
qu'un jour tu étais tu étais tu étais
amoureux de l'amour on va dire et merde
j'espère qu'on va avoir une belle
séquence déjà content et très active
avec les garçons aussi
ouais ça voilà tu m'avais dit je regarde
son fils qui
merci ouais voilà voilà mots voilà
l'amour à on enchaîne mois